cuz like this is what it is
alright cool hey what's going on where
you been it's up I missed you I was on
the East Coast seeing family working
from the New York office that's
important family is good you're at PAX I
went to PAX West I had a wonderful time
a lot of my GameSpot brethren what did I
call you we didn't call each other
anything I'm just saying I call you a
lot of things
oh right I'm Mary I invited you yes let
me preface this you guys with saying
obviously we took three weeks off so
it's really important for us to come in
and record we had a bit of an audio
issue and I've also had a problem with
the PlayStation that I'm using the disk
just like pops right out it's just a
bummer or you want to pepper on us
fullscreen change it to the PIP as soon
as you can soon as you're and into the
thing change it to PIP anyway we noticed
that our mics were down so we boosted
them as much as possible I still think
they're too low let me know in the
comments if they're too low or if the
whole audio mix is too low we can fix it
next time it just got to a point where
it was like 20 minutes in and we were
like let's just do it so I apologize and
I will look into it when it's not a
Thursday evening in our last option to
play can evil before the weekend and I
really wanted to get this up for the
weekend yeah sorry probably god-willing
I mean if this thing spits out my disk
again I don't know what we're gonna do
besides can the episode and get another
frickin PlayStation tomorrow you know
it's weird the people watching right now
can see like the timestamp of the video
and know whether we have no clue in the
future it's riveting game all the more
intense it is it is intense its intense
not just because of this climactic
cutscene where we will grab a rope at
the last second
nice but also that my playstation keeps
spitting out but God dang discs and then
we can't and I'm the one I'm the one
with the account like I invite you so if
I get caught out it like ruins the whole
save it's Japan this is Eric tase
PlayStation and I don't approve of it
your arch nemesis Oh
I'm climbing right up in your butt why
is it showing us that elevator who's in
that Sheri and Jake oh there's a lady
oh yeah
and help us out but we opted to use this
that would be Resident Evil to be ready
medieval plus somebody looks like I'm
punching you in the butt
okay so you do your thing and I will
every once in a while come out and
protect you
get him up zombie I gotta got him
where's your hand drop me ammo over
there in the [ __ ] there's like four of
them I might need your help
can I kick them off that thing oh right
don't do that made a bad call
Magnum dude that keeps happening to me
I'm like full of ammo I don't want
and then night oh [ __ ]
no I don't want to do I we're almost
done with Leon's campaign Leon champagne
how's your all right cool I did nothing
I like shot that guy once yeah Simmons
like when does he die gotcha girl climb
up my crotch grab climb up my bod
[Music]
not my day why they not even using their
legs I mean what they're showing
yes it's like an interesting thing where
it seems areas should I climb faster
okay it's cut seems just like a victim
of them
like seriously how are you not dead yet
we shot him so many times that part yeah
God he's so obsessed with Anita
why aren't it why are you so obsessed
with me sure why her hair is really
tussle and learned to cover you Oh
Simmons
Simmons is IQ before mom should I like
I don't feel like I'm doing anything I
can't I can't move I did it he's dead
what look at her [ __ ] hair it's so
distracting
I'm gonna die
you're shooting with my mag no cool
become a human oh [ __ ] shot that dude's
face off
all right no peeking
so quick that better okay
it's there's no pics on the net
it was a trap
what do you want from me oh you [ __ ]
pick me up he's doing [ __ ] to me I think
I might be dead
[Music]
yes I got sniper hello like if it's not
one thing it's another I'm gonna [ __ ]
die there's like zombies and
Oh
[Music]
maybe it's for the best that my mics are
down maybe that happened because I
scream along and people are sick of it
[ __ ]
shoot him Calvin
I was in with all like the QuickTime
events like they were pretty enjoyable
but the boss fight that is like 10 years
old is like it's really starting to get
something what do you want oh for [ __ ]
sake guy can run nope wait is this a
part of it I saw this [ __ ] scene with
Who Framed Roger Rabbit
he's only got so many titties on the
thing on the edge on the edge that's a
kill shot weird
[Music]
is that what does it
hi why didn't we try fire oh my god that
is such a long ba fight
what he can't yell that that's a weird
very very well-written text for
happening in the split second on the top
of a burning skyscraper are you waiting
for get her no said John Cusack movie
now I would do anything for love now
we're back how is this not over if that
boss comes back I'm like I don't know
what to say
we better fight like a de or something
where's our ticket out of here where's
Mike get to it
now we have fire powers
hi
no neither does this game you're
probably gonna get with how do you
Simmons Simmons I'm sure they saved a
room for you and help a room it's a
suite all right I'm gonna take care of
the zombie oh whoa whoa something
something bit me
hey my guy got stabbed by his own branch
fire oh you got hit
oh my god which one [ __ ] yeah this
bossfight sucks where are they coming
from where are they coming from
what god I can't even attack this boss
now how does the branch go down
died
[Music]
no when he should sit this one out
languishing are they humping him what
orgy
wait there's ammo back here so it's
definitely not over uh that's what we
thought last time
I'm putting all these on the ground
all right hurry up I know but this game
is like maybe another 10 minutes like
make it happen that's what we thought
if I had reviewed this game back in the
day my line would have been I thought it
was over ten minutes ago the whole game
the whole game I was thinking this is
nice roof wrong room
[Music]
you know you ready
get up there it's like been the same guy
first so long
go get a girl oh my god he's like a crab
meteor what was that there's like a big
wasp in my what are you doing it's
amazing are you like moving the elevator
it's so good honest you in your friggin
eye
now he's walking out it's concerning I
shot ya
Wow are you I'm not what the [ __ ]
fighting a bunch listen I'm not worried
about your integrity of like fighting I
just have this fly in my face and I am
out of like ammo I'm all clear get out
of there where are we going
hey I agree this is bad no you don't
want to okay yeah he's like a fly
he's like a fly guy or something like I
guess he's like harnessing there like
zombie power or something
they're not even explaining it anymore
oh he's hiding his eyes they don't even
have the [ __ ] common decency to say
like you'll find out soon enough
any moisture we've got to use these
watch out
how are you still a lot of shooting his
sax what sax oh he's like little
underarm sack tell me when is gross
eyeballs are
there's orange [ __ ]
are you dead might be a cop no less I
get it I'm dead
good God doesn't need to be that long
how much do you think we've to do again
at the damn ammo so just get his like
little underarm sax and then be done
with it right yeah and then you all know
that like Sinai's the lightning rod
through that zombie is important too
I don't even know what that means that
big orange thing can I skip
that I think that comes into play
oh right I mean it is really late
yeah I'm shooting
make it a clean shot
you could shoot this on his leg there we
go oh he's shoot his legs show me your
eyes off [ __ ] I'm gonna try to keep
you safe from zombies but oh that looks
important is that how he makes new legs
okay so you shoot off a leg and he gets
the zombie to regenerate and it
electrifies them oh [ __ ] what wait look
at me yes you look like a giant electric
chopstick no don't kill him I'm trying
appalling sorry yeah alright so shoot
his legs whoa yeah there's like there's
a soft spot on it
right there see where I'm shooting my
god like they all look soft
actually I'm gonna go
like I'm so out of touch come on come on
suck up that dude suck up that dude
people kill everybody else so he has to
talk about okay you took did you take
off enough legs
oh he [ __ ] me up I think you have to
kill everybody else but that one too
I'm shoot this little ball be areas it's
hard
know how confident I am in my system
I'm not sure that he should do it so she
decided you're getting the I shot this
shucks man out do it pick them up
pick him up and get puted
then his I sin it's friggin I
good now you're dead may this be the end
of it
yes guys head for the chopper this floor
isn't stable
I'm
I'm amazed this is gone on as long as it
has probably got the chute from the shop
yep there's an RPG here
like how many testers do you think they
had and someone probably was like boy
this has been a long fight we should
call it
[Music]
and they were like no let's make them a
hoarseness
rocket washer all right kind of weak the
eyeballs
that was it good job you're braver than
I
it's very lucky that those rocket
launchers were by that helicopter one
more form form of but like all the other
stuff we did didn't ok anytime like some
guys in mortal like that I usually they
have to explode like blow him up into
such a form that he cannot regenerate he
looks like he he just crawl off that
thing oh it's the umbrella
like this like that's a cool visual but
it it's hollow after what happened to
the chopper so red
oh my god all right let's get out of
here I just don't know why we're playing
I thought that would be that it's like
not a good sign that we're playing it's
not a good sign that we're still playing
80 Wong lungs
these are the colors I picked for fall
this is an SD card with my nudes
she's so modern this is evidence that
prove Simmons guilt or innocence
mine and rector is Mikey we're gonna
need six million Washington Monument
where why couldn't my Kiev coming at us
what's he doing looking back on his loss
he'll love it
that's you goodbye what was the point of
making it playable for us to walk from
one side of the hell bed to the hell
length of gameplan
did we do it please oh my god show me
the credits and I'm Chris we got some
time I got like half an hour left we can
play some Chris campaign if you want
yeah do you want to do another episode
that wasn't that long you probably just
do the same episode we kind of tease
next one or start Chris now okay
I hope the UH okay
I just hope the disc doesn't come out of
my god damn well it happened before but
it might not happen again cuz it looks
like it's been in there for 30 minutes
it's get press the right side I just
pressed everybody Merry Christmas should
have to be peers Oh
oh my god I actually don't care
Deborah supposed to be such a like how
old a powerful scene did you drink both
one of those was supposed to be for me
Wow I didn't say anything
trash trash man trashing him in its
water house that trash
he was hyping up these drinks to me
we drank both of them it's why I'm upset
the Secret Service is here we need these
Wheat Thins [ __ ]
the investigating Commission have
reviewed the evidence and feel it unjust
to hold you liable for Simmons crime
they will also not be disclosing their
findings to the public he assisted the
same mass biological terrorism and she's
like no it's cool I think I could be
very wrong
she was just following orders in my ass
but for 20 years this gun has been in my
ass
he's didn't want them to get it so he
shoved it up his ass
he's gun women here that Zoey said yeah
it was actually very timely and a
long-ass draft look ridiculous episode
with a sexist joke Leon how about we go
over to my place and do some overtime
this in case you ever were concerned if
I was sexualized throughout this game
I'm just gonna commit to it I was
looking at her stats
nice
[Music]
sweet all right
just invite me I don't know uh does this
mean what's new game+ that's not what it
should be yeah do new game+ are you sure
yes but a Chris still haven't decided on
Jake and sherry yet I don't wait that
was just one I thought that was the
second one
that's what no now we're I'm Pierce
Nivens yes
[Music]
I guess I'm I'm Chris okay I think I
have to start the game right yeah I
create the game session and then I
invite you
inviting nobody look his name's that's
your Smurf account that's why it has
such a few trophies
aha okay I want to tell you the story
that I told everyone I was that PAX West
thanks prime if you want to call it that
we were walking down the [ __ ]
sidewalk and a woman in a man wearing
these fanciest clothes came out of their
hotel obviously just were there for
vacation or something she was wearing
this beautiful gown and he was wearing
like a nice ass suit she came out and
like looked around and he came out and
he swear to God he said what a bunch of
nerds just looked at her well you are a
nerd all right no but it just seems so
unnecessary like something that would
have happened in middle school but the
dude was like definitely in his 30s and
just hadn't let it go what a bunch of
nerds come on honey it's Chris
sweetheart yeah sweetheart you here to
pour drinks pretty how about you shut
your mouth
Wow yeah yeah is this a protagonist like
I suck Chris Redfield
okay sucks oh five and one girl well you
suck yeah
I'm confused am I supposed to like this
guy okay
never thought I'd find Chris Redfield
wasting awareness like this yeah you
[ __ ] are you pick the boy sector got
way she ever seen here you read the
script this guy kind of look at this a
little like you did he did Chris not and
he's too drunk to notice the BSAA
BIOS logo on your shoulder you say he
looks like me not that guy here's the
piers a little bit he's got your little
button nose yeah a little deceased
deceased deceased to see do over to them
to remember Chris if you walk away now
and I I look like Chris Redfield a
little bit six months of searching for
you a sexist [ __ ]
you're never never be rude to your
bartender she will [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
it's been my lifelong goal to own my own
bar and just be an [ __ ] to people who
treat me like bad
everyone's waiting everyone
there's a bar in Australia called mana
bar these are all BSA members yeah they
were sitting around letting that guide
should treat that woman badly that guy
looks like Tai root my old manager
I like time
we moved to Texas to be with other Texan
I can't keep running away I have to face
the truth I have to face the truth
that's the only way I'll ever remember
the only way I'll get my life back hg 2
alpha T bio change in vision suppress
the bioterror outbreak while proceedings
an Ace of Spades Ace of Spades
hi
Mikey don't die down there
we've added Chris after original five oh
my god I'll miss you guys all right turn
it back down turn the gameplay down
media chance cuz okay cool cuz it's
gonna be a fire fight there's some ammo
over here look how different our Oh why
would they change that different
campaign different it's very strange
I mean I just don't know why it's
necessary is it because they wanted to
market it as like three totally
different games like I'm not mad about
it not like annoyed or anything no
dammit hey that's just my state of being
yeah it's um you know like some people
have resting [ __ ] I have like just
[ __ ] face just resting [ __ ] yeah no
I'm not resting it doesn't matter what
as well look at this oh my god those
guys are monsters they like can't be
killed
sir
sir how do I crouch again
let me get some [ __ ] a mix of civvies
and hostels how did you catch I'm
sitting and spinning you aim and then
you go backwards I hope he enjoyed I
know I did a heroic PSA is moving on
target here we have our client here up
here's Nivens here's the event
I know it's iconic it's such a classic
name goodness cooking right away so
spades
let's do line where Thanks
oh man I even read this the ice raids
definitely so what are we doing here
we're gonna kick that guy off all right
it worked out military your brozen that
was in the military right uh what is he
in no reasoning with these bastards in
the Marines for eight years they did
like three tours in Iraq two in
Afghanistan
and now he's in the Army
counterintelligence
oh wow my father was a corporal he was a
zombie in the war like eyes got too many
eyes and he's got a gun
a lot of eyes and a gun yeah my father
served
there's just me and my sisters none of
us went for it so I don't know a lot of
army speak is what I'm trying to say
Tango Foxtrot whiskey huh
that's just stuff you hear in the movies
like what's something they don't say in
the movie you know Joe there's is that
something they say in the army trying to
wrap my head oh no it's fubar in here
ace of spades all right we need three
more minutes it's a box of chocolates in
here what what he's got a knife got a
noise I think there's one more guy maybe
under the sea
oh you did why China
how come every time you're in a foreign
country run down like China's a night
it's a cool place I've never been to
China sigh from what I've heard it's not
a forever slum like we're seeing in
parts I'm sure it's all right Prince
again why couldn't they show us 80% of
San Francisco's pretty trashed right now
what look I can't just turn he runs in
such wide circles
look it I can't just turn in a circle
that's me trying to turn tight if you
want a super heel you turn on a dime
oh we got new melee attack from behind
right did actually go to Japan like what
would the Japanese like Japanese
developers I wonder if they make to
Pamela
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful maybe it was busted because we
both were doing it piers
[Music]
Pinto there's also the Santa Maria
well it's just like sometimes I feel
like their only job is to dies you can
see what things are capable
this is kind of like that Rick and Morty
episode
we're motor has a giant iron
don't have any
[Music]
got a big arm but I feel like he doesn't
how to use it
Oh twist a single shot somehow I'm going
yeah
[Music]
I wish I had more goddamn
where is this
like [ __ ] idiot you up here hey you
want to come over here Oh got him to
stay here and tend to the wounded sorry
I didn't you all they're up the thing
and then down hey over here
piers hurry up Paris Cheers
yeah I'm here Hey
[Music]
that's what my father called armed all
right
I like don't have some very confusing
when I when I broke my arm in fifth
grade helos there's some ammo in here
you know what how are you alive I shot I
shot so much of your body
Wow look at the recoil in the sniper
oh no I [ __ ] hit a bonsai tree and I
definitely okay look at me when I shoot
wait where did you get that I just have
it yeah
wait do I have anything like that all
right what else all right I think that's
it well I haven't my other guns a
submachine gun okay so meet bsaa dude
I feel like I'm getting money but I
don't want it I want oh I found a thing
some peers have a lot in common with
extreme caution we've heard on the radio
there's been rumor of men with machetes
in giant arms and ceramic masks please
advise
we're saying the other day of it
the term please advise in an email kind
of just means [ __ ] you in like corporate
speak wow it's just kind of like a way
to say like what the [ __ ] am I supposed
to do with this you deal with it
like I've been told this
shoot advice what's in these jars jars
pickled oh my god
peers peers classmates colleagues peers
contemporaries I got it all right let's
go a few more minutes gets it or unless
this is oh let's get to the next how
long is this one supposed to take a
million years as well
well what is a skew stand for that
tenement building up I had is the ace of
spades
what up nerd
I am in a knife that
wait Harlequin right I'm gonna all nice
this game maybe that's our different
things aren't going too well over at the
three of diamonds they need you down
there three of diamonds you ever see our
Mississippi grind came out a couple
years ago with Brian Reynolds and Bill
Mendelsohn talk about cards
Wow Wow like I turned into a flame burn
his ad to the man how symbolic
yeah we rolling
everybody dead all right
[Music]
all we doing that thing where we slide
hold on yeah I guess the muscle memory
saved me they're taking a little fire
you couldn't be more likely to die make
it happen
I'm climbing a pipe here from the front
from the front from the front from the
front from noon noon I got shot
typically when you get shot in this
scenario you would that's cute
where am i taking fire from
boy I don't want anymore money I need
some [ __ ] ammo I got you covered
listen okay I like didn't know what I
just found a place so I don't have to
relay can I get that cover that's
actually I'm not even taking fire so it
takes a while to do the pulse action on
this right but if i zoom in while it's
happening surprise
I guess I
in more ways and you can imagine
stop giving me money like I need ammo
this is dumb give me I'm a prick filthy
rich I don't know but there's a Birdman
over here Birdman
okay one Birdman down to Birdman to go
all right that's two down over here find
these pipes okay and then check out
these five see that's exactly something
Pearson says that's okay it's kind of
like that show that's but he chooses not
to because that's wrong he's morally
opposed to it she saw the future
she was also funny
HQ - Alpha Team you're almost at the Ace
of Spades why did you not trip also
that's why I'm the captain
show your stupid head you ugly man
did not Oh what was that just some
healthy notes up here yeah I can cancel
them there's a ladder up here
[Music]
there's a shootie barrel here it seems
like it might come in handy
Wow I have a [ __ ] ton of grenade Oh
balls I feel like yes but not alone
Kristen really threw out the ace of
spades team has been dispatched to
assist with search and rescue stand by
for instructions stand by for the nut I
needed a break that we're gonna get
attacked so preserve these barrels
the zombies that nobody used the lights
and I happen I'm taking heavy bullets
did he tell me to keep my panties on
oh I fell down the spear not working
oh that's right I thought it was broken
but it was user error
that's right earlier
that's for drinking my soda
Oh balls I got hit with a second giant
arm mm-hm
I got arms how many of these asses do we
have to kill until the door how did you
play destiny you play destiny how is it
I like it do you
you were kill a lot of people until
those opening the door
Megaton hammer watch out serving it
so are we going to Mikey
it looks like we are because the NPCs
are forward and the NPCs are never
forward what if I oh I caught that
called us back to that door skivvies
to be I thought your skivvies were like
your undies both hold on to your undies
gentlemen all right a lot Don I feel
like the Earth's us pirates we're back
rescue the hostages on the 1st and 7th
you're back then get out of the building
Knievel's back everything's back calming
yeah the Ace of Spades you're back
spoilers we will be back next week or
next episode more of a 0-6 see you then
there's machete men
and a red bucket I went too far I went
really far